We seriously need to talk about what
Patrick Bet David just casually admitted
to millions of value tamement viewers.
>> It's either dirt or you've got leverage
of mutual interest. It's either dirt or
you've got leverage of mutual interest.
I want to invite you to add something
powerful to your saddaka jar list.
[music] We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly.
>> Just imagine this.
>> You help someone learn with how to pray,
>> how to recite fat,
>> every
prayer for the rest of their lives.
>> You share in a reward.
>> When they [music] teach their children
>> and their children's children,
>> the reward continues for you. For just
£100,
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people like
me.
>> Learn salah. Donate today and earn
rewards that never stop.
>> Brothers and sisters in de I've got
another video for you guys of Patrick
David. Um I don't know if you did this
intentionally. I'm very sure it's
unintentionally admitting that Israel is
using a blackmail ring, a blackmail
islanding island via Epstein to
blackmail politicians, US politicians
and twist their arms to do certain
things. So the question is who's the
country run by? Besides that, the
question is now his co-host uh I think
his name is Vinnie absolutely
annihilates them and I'm going to give
it to him. That's his boss there.
Patrick is his boss, but he goes ham. So
much so he puts so much pressure that
even Patrick David, the scum of this
earth who hasn't made one tweet against
the gardens, had Benjamin Netanyahu on
his podcast, the dirt of the dirt that
hates Islam and hates Muslim. Here is
how it transpired and it's shocking. So,
so in this sense, man, when it comes to
like, you know, Iran or Muslims and and
Israel and Jewish people, I'm sorry,
just Israel in general. So, and I don't
want to say lesser of the two evils, but
in this game that we're playing, you
you're leaning towards the side because
I mean, one side's doing horrible stuff,
the other side's doing horrible stuff.
Are you going with the side that's it's
more beneficial because the other side
is more evil?
>> You know what it is, Candace? Guess
what? Why don't she run in 2028 and her
number one thing should be get rid of
Apac and Israel lobby? See what it does.
>> Good luck.
>> No, no. What I'm saying is run on that.
I'm actually not saying good luck. I'm
not. He's saying
>> I'm going to praise Candace Owens here
because she's put so much pressure on
these goons that they are look look
they're literally she the pressure she's
putting is working. Carry on Candace.
Carry on Tucker. I would say carry on
Charlie Cook if he's alive today and
didn't get assassinated by Israel.
>> You want Trump's top five to be Israel?
No. By the way, every single president
since Nixon days had a hard time
negotiating with Israel. Every single
one of them. Apac. Do do you want them
in there or do you want them out?
>> I want them out.
>> Yeah. So, it's like a
>> helped you. Of course.
>> This is such a like a
>> What do you mean APAC helped you? The
people are only talking about APAC help.
Apac helps theirelves. What do you do
investment of 100 million and get
billions in return? That's fantastic
investment in return. But
>> they're getting they're getting what
they want and what they feel their
interests are.
>> But are we supposed to let them get away
with murder just because the enemy is
way worse at doing murder? That's my
point. Exactly. Now you guys can go. And
who is the enemy here that I don't
really believes this that is way worse
than murder. Who who when have the
Muslims ever committed a genocide
against a specific nation like genuine
Muslims who have gone and done what
Israel has ever done. Muslims have
always fought mento men. They don't.
It's against our religious harm in we
don't do collective punishment. That's
Israel biblically and that's their
morale. That's their That's their
morality.
>> You're failing to understand. Please,
please tell me what
>> and you just think of this in in
non-emotional reaction like I'm in love
with Candace Owens and everything she
says I love digest I'm just saying go
look look how they they tried to insult
him as you know loving Candice Owens
Candace Owens is a thorn in their neck
let's see what this Adam snake whatever
his name is absolute scumbag who's a
puppet for Israel himself is an Israel
himself what else do you expect from him
>> okay
>> there's no perfect country on earth bro
>> I know that
>> do you though
>> yeah I just I criticize Bush while I was
in the military. That's why I left the
military. Continue. Yeah. So, you've
been critical of your own government.
>> Thousand%.
>> These are your NATO partners. This is
Israel. This is Japan. This is South
Korea. Every single one of these
countries we've had issues with. We've
gone to war with Germany and now they're
our ally. We've gone to war with Japan.
We've gone to war with Italy. So, at
some point, if everything we DO IS YEAH,
BUT THE NAZIS, OH MY PEARL HARBOR, IT'S
LIKE you're never going to get ahead. So
you want to DO THAT? OH MY GOD, CANDACE
ONCE TOLD ME ABOUT USS LIBERTY. I GET
IT.
>> NO, she didn't. Mean me and Tom had
that.
>> Awesome. You found out for yourself, but
none of this belittle USS Liberty when
American soldiers were attacked by their
ally, which by their own ally. Yeah. And
they were trying to cover that up and
shush it. Yes. Israel was trying to kill
everyone on that ship so nobody talks.
Okay. So they can use it as a false
attack. They're coming for your
children. Like Candace said, they're
coming for American children and people
have seen through it. is new. The the
JFK conspiracies, the Bolevik revolution
thing. Is Israel has been dealing with
this forever. You think Israel has is
just this perfect country that is
innocent, that has never done anything
wrong? No.
>> Have they been held accountable for any
of it?
>> Go ahead. Are you the guy? No. No.
Because you're full of a question. No.
No. No. Because you are
>> You're full of crap, mate. You are
absolutely full of crap. Yes. Okay. Have
they even been ever taken account for
it?
>> You love Israel. You can't Adam. They
can do whatever they want. I acknowledge
they can do whatever they want.
>> They are a better ally than enemy.
>> But you're saying they can get away with
living because we're supposed to forget
about it.
>> That's not what I'm saying. That's
horseshit.
>> Who Who has done worse things to
America?
>> Okay, listen for a second. Don't be
emotional.
>> No. How am I not going to be emotional
attacked America worse in the last 100
years? Germany or Israel?
>> Germany or Israel?
>> Yeah. Who's had more deaths of
Americans? Germany or Israel?
This isn't a trick question. This isn't
tough, bro.
>> Killing Americans. Yes. Killing
Americans
>> in war.
>> In a war.
>> Germany.
>> Okay, great. Who's killed more
Americans? Japan or Israel?
>> Japan.
>> Okay, good. So, so, so, so what's I
don't understand. What's what's his
point? They they're not your allies. You
were at war with them. Were you
expecting them to throw flowers at you?
The question is this backfires on him.
Vinnie didn't quote it even though he
replies back to him. You have an ally
that has attacked USS Liberty is has
assassinated JF Kennedy. Let's be
honest, it's an open secret. You've got
the Mossad agents laughing when 9/11 to
Twin Towers are being attacked by
so-called Muslims. Yes. Okay. Muslims.
Yeah. Okay. Um cheering and laughing.
Yes. They are involved in industries
like the pornography industry, gay
industry, gambling industry, you name
it. That are corrupting your youth. Your
people
promoting degeneracy. They are behind
Hollywood Zionist. They are behind
everything. The Zionist. Yes. Okay. And
you're here talking about that. And hold
on a second. Your own ally is attacking
you. Your own ally. Yes. Charlie Kirk
and the rest. The list goes on. Okay. Is
slapping around your politicians. So
Japan and Germany, yes, in a war
attacked, but they're not an ally. How
is your own ally attacking and
controlling you to this level and
killing your own children, you [__]
Your arguing backfires on you. Okay, but
you just proved my point. So you can't
Hold on, Adam. So you just proved my
point. So you have a point.
>> USS Liberty. USS Liberty dancing
Israelis cheering. Cheering at night.
The [__] towers were coming down
cheering. They all were part of
intelligence.
>> So why aren't you yelling and bitching
about Japan or Japan? because they're
not our freaking our our
>> Because because they're because their
prime minister doesn't come to Congress
and everybody stands up and worships him
like he's Jesus Christ. Because they
know who the the guy in charge is, Adam.
They're not our Hold on. Are they bigger
allies? Do we give them as much money as
we give to Israel and they could do
whatever they want. And you're failing
to go back to what I said about Candace.
You're not an anti-semite. You don't
hate Jews because you're criticizing
Israel. And I get it. The Muslim world,
the Muslim world in Europe is doing what
they're doing. I get it. I get it. But
with zero accountability, that means
Adam, in a 100 years from now, we're
going to go, "Well, get guess what? They
did it. And who cares? Because they're
our allies, so they can get away with
murder."
>> So there's there's dozens of wars going
on all around the world.
>> Yes.
>> Why aren't you talking about the closest
ally? Because Adam, my tax dollars, so
much wars going about the genocide. Let
me see what they want. Again, running
from accountability. Has Israel ever
been accounted for? No. If any other
country on planet earth did what they
done, man, America invaded Iraq to
liberate the Muslim woman, you know, or
m
weapons of mass destruction. Okay. Uh
yeah. Okay. My tax dollars are going to
what's happening over there in Gaza,
Adam, and if you've been keeping toll of
the death count of children and
everything that sits on my mind cuz at
what point is that going to stop? When
is that going to end? And by the way,
again, wait, let me guess. Because I
said that I support Hamas and I hate
Jews. Is that what it is? Is that what
it is?
>> There you go. Him. He even knows
speaking the truth that 70 plus thousand
children, innocent men, women, children,
babies, kids have been massacred and
that would make him in Hamas and he
knows that they all know and see through
that brother and sisters. Yeah. And this
is what we need to propagate and push
and show the world the reality of how
evil these scum Zionists are. This how
scum they are. that him saying that this
is wrong makes him a what? He had to
preempt it. Oh, I'm a hammer now.
>> I don't want to see any deaths of
anyone,
>> man. But the numbers are staggering in
the other way. When is that going to
stop?
>> Good luck in this position you're taking
because all you're doing is aligning
yourself with Iran.
>> Oh, here we see. See, and and that's it.
Because you always have to have a take a
side, Adam. How about this? America, how
I don't know how hard this is to
understand. I am US first. I don't give
a [__] about BB Netanyahu. I don't give
a [__] about German. I don't CARE ABOUT
FRANCE. I DON'T care about anybody but
the United States of America first. Once
we're secure, then we can go talk to
other people.
>> Then Vinnie, unfortunately, you're a
child
>> because every grownup country
>> has allies.
>> I never said allies. Adam, once you
served in the military, then you could
talk all this [__]
>> Oh, there you go. If you say that, you
support Iran. You can't get out of with
these people. You cannot get it out with
these people. Yes. You can't say
nothing. If you speak the truth, you
support Iran. How do you how how do you
win that argument?
>> I think that well let's I think you
could look around the globe in terms of
diplomacy. Why is any country not held
accountable? Because they skill
>> here. Listen very carefully guys cuz
here is where Patrick David
intentionally unintentionally willingly
unwillingly exposes Israel finally. It
came out their mouth like Allah says in
the Quran on the day where your hands
are going to speak against you. He it
just came out. Check this out guys.
hopefully prevent themselves from being
held accountable and they make friends
and do things in certain ways so that
they'll say, "Look, look, you know, I
know you uh borrowed my car and you did
a lot of damage to it,
>> but I really need your help at school
because we're both on the same football
team. I'm going to overlook the car and
we got to be teammates over here."
That's how diplomacy works.
>> Since uh uh uh you can even go John F.
Kennedy, you can go to Carter, you can
go to all these guys,
>> Kennedy and Robert McBurn,
>> none of these guys have ever been able
to negotiate favorable terms for the US.
Why do you think that is
>> good? So look, look one second. So in a
nutshell with the example they gave with
the car being damaged, a football team,
etc. They're basically saying that they
are strategically consistent, not
morally. They don't care about anyone's
morals. They are saying you got that on
me. You've done this, but I need you to
do this favor. So, it's a tit for tat in
the sense where you do that favor, but
you got me my back there and I'm going
to get your back here. It they do not
give two craps about who's dying, who's
being killed. Nada, we've got Epson
files on you. Okay, you know what? Okay,
you got my back there. I'll get your
back here. And that's exactly what's
happened. and they are leading you to
the path of a war with Iran at their
cost
>> because either Israel has got things on
us and we are not without sin or they
have been able to lobby successfully to
talk us out of it. It's one of the two.
>> That's unbelievable guys. Can you
imagine this? One, either they are
blackmailing you, they got something on
you, or number two, look at number two,
they're lobbying. They're spending money
and trying to manipulate, gaslight, and
interfere with politics. So, one way or
another, we're going to do it forcefully
or we're going to do it via payments.
We're going to bribe you or force you.
You can't make this crap up.
>> Okay. So, which one you think it's more?
>> I think there's probably a little bit
more chess game on some of the stuff
we've done CIA around the world. And
they've got that. And they're also just
incredibly skillful omniresent
lobbyists. So they probably also have
some dirt on us to say, "Hey, if you do
this, guess what?" Like the whole thing
with uh Epstein when his brother came
over and and uh by the time he walked
away, I was convinced both he and his
brother were part of MSAD.
>> Interesting. Interesting. Someone's
waking up or should we say they were
awake. There's a reason. I wonder why
Patrick David has chosen to um you know
address this now finally. And uh uh if I
have to put money on the fact that
Epstein has a lot of dirt on god knows
how many people as a MSAD agent and
sending those assets back to Israel, how
valuable would that be? It
>> very valuable. So I'll make my answer
shorter because you're asking me to and
I will and I will.
>> Very valuable. Very valuable. Now check
how he just brings this this guy whoever
I don't know if it's maybe ex CIA. Look
what he says. Listen carefully. The two
things he says I'm going to I'm just
going to listen the butt. Let's just go
to the crux of the matter. It's either
dirt or you've got leverage of mutual
interest.
>> It's either dirt or you've got leverage
of mutual interest.
Finally, Patrick Bet David, I don't
think, you know, I think people put so
much pressure on him showed that what
kind of a hypocrite he is. He had to
come out somehow. But even then, no,
this video that I was reacting to was
through a different channel. Look what
the commentator had to say on this
matter.
>> What a wild and completely disturbing
ending to the PBD podcast. We seriously
need to talk about what Patrick Bet
David just casually admitted to millions
of value tamement viewers. Patrick
BetDavid basically said that foreign
intelligence agencies use extreme
blackmail, specifically naming Jeffrey
Epstein to control powerful American
politicians and secure billions in US
funding. But instead of getting outraged
about this massive corruption, Patrick
Bet David just smiles, calls it the
game, and says that is just how politics
works. Are you kidding me? When you
accept foreign blackmail and dark money
as just a game, you are normalizing the
absolute betrayal of the American
taxpayer. If American leaders are
controlled by leverage, they are no
longer working for us. Period. And then
you have Adam Sausnik, who completely
embarrassed himself. Adam loves to play
the tough guy, but here he completely
rolls over for foreign interests. Adam,
>> that's it guys. Subhan Allah. Allah
subhanaa tala is exposing them and Allah
plans and they plan. They plan and Allah
plans. Allah is the best of planners. So
when it comes to this matter, brother
sisters, you really need to educate your
friends, neighbors, etc., whoever it is
on this matter because the more we put
this out there, the more we can see the
reality of what they're doing and this
is having a massive impact
geopolitically, brothers and sisters,
that for us to talk about this matter
and for people to wake up, that is where
change comes. For centuries, the the the
the Westerners have been lied to about
Islam, Islam, Islam, Muslim, Muslim,
terrorist, terrorist, terrorist. People
are seeing right through it. Right
through it. And that's why because of
these videos that we're doing to bring
light to this matter. And you need to
aid this matter by sharing this with
your non-Muslim friends and making and
being aware. So when these talking
points come, you know what to say.
Brothers and sisters, nothing else
should be said. Alhamdulillah. May Allah
carry on exposing them. And by falsehood
like Allah says, falsehood is going to
um when truth is taken, falsehood
perishes for falsehood based on its
assel is bound to perish. from sisters
inshallah. Hope you guys enjoy the
video.